furniture made from sail cloth is
waterproof inflatable and mobile these
designs are by agata Coolican pavelka
morskie from Gdansk the husband-and-wife
team worked together as the designer duo
mala for lab lab Louis with our
furniture is inspired by the traditional
sail cloth of this region there are lots
of workshops here in Gdansk that make
the best sales for customers around the
world we produce our chairs and sofas in
the same tradition not only do we use
the same material the seams and joins
are also made in the same way as argued
it takes about a minute for the limp
material to become design objects for
the living room they're inspired by the
beach and a maritime lifestyle
Agathe Cooley camp avowed primorsky live
in the countryside [ __ ] dansk this is
where they designed their furniture with
this small addition a standard ladder
can be converted into an elevated thrown
the to seek to blend functionality with
a touch of irony with us we need to
assume we're not interested in regular
wooden chairs belong there no we charge
our stools no charge this gonna pass
puppy air we don't make normal sofas
either go to your zone music we make
them out of paper or sail cloth washing
its lucky we like to Holly with
contrasts when we design but we still
take our job is designer seriously the
furniture must be functional that's the
main thing but there's always some kind
of ingenuity on the plate pavan yet
downstairs in the workshop Pavel /
morskie is working on the latest project
this structure is a custom design for
the port city of Gdynia near Gdansk and
is made for bathers to relax on as they
float on the sea creative designers from
around the world are currently meeting
at the former Tempelhof Airport in
Berlin it's the annual d my design
festival this year Poland is the focus
so of course mala for are making an
appearance it was important for us to
come here as so many products from
Poland are being shown here in Berlin
now everyone can see that design is also
important to us in Poland so bikies
maharani our optic nerve
forty polish designers were invited to
the festival never before have so many
designers from Poland displayed works in
Germany at the same time visitors are
making new discoveries like he stools by
design label tab under or this coat
stand by Tamara garlic also his door he
has oh yeah historically Poland has been
more of a place for production rather
than designed last two or three years
we've seen the design industry becoming
more important for Poland and more and
more polish designers are working for
international companies in internet
scene islands I name are biting over the
past few years polish economic growth
has been surging Yakub chastely works in
warsaw as an architect and designer for
a growing number of affluent customers
it's only now in the last couple of
years that people start to need polish
things and they feel a pride of having
their own polish designs not expensive
Italian sofas so it's probably some
moment in the development of of our
society many young creative people are
now moving to the port city of dice and
its neighboring coastal towns Pavel
primorsky and Agatha kulick themselves
studied at the dance academy of fine
arts mumbles versus for the mega to our
customers are excited about design their
German French Italian or Spanish but
very few were polish when you think we
can change that by designing nice things
and getting involved in interesting
projects Oh break on Tameka she's a
McGee break the line in Dublin play in
2012 mala for won the red dot award for
their sofa the duo stand for new
innovative design from Poland
you